- I am a genius!
- This is incredible.
- Nobody understands.
- You talked us out of that.
- It's true!
(man laughing)
You did talk her out of the right answer.
- Lost my game.
- All right, one last time, come on.
(suspenseful music)
(woman screaming)
- I'm gonna play an iconic horror scream,
and you guys are gonna guess which one.
- You're gonna give multiple choice,
and then we're going to decide?
- [Interviewer] Yes, exactly.
- I see.
- Cool. Let's go for it.
- Okay.
(woman screaming)
- [Anthony Michael Hall] "Scream."
- I'm going with Shelley
Duvall, The Shining.
- You guys are right.
(bell dings)
It is Shelley Duvall.
- Nice going.
- Hey, yes!
(woman screaming)
- Okay. That was Psycho.
- Mommy.
(bell dings)
- Was it mommy?
- Mommy, yeah.
(quizzer laughs)
- Okay.
(man screeching)
- [Jason Blum] I'ma go Wicker Man.
- [David Gordon Green]
You wanna go Wicker Man?
Jamie, what do you think?
- I'll go with, yeah.
- Because I hate horror movies,
I'm gonna go with whatever you guys say.
(host laughing)
- She hates them.
- This is the greatest game ever.
I love games.
- Okay.
- James Caan.
- I was gonna say James Caan.
- You are correct.
(bell dings)
- And it's exact-
- I'm killing it over here!
(man claps)
- Well, unfortunately-
- What?
- [Host] you guys were wrong,
this was James Caan,
(buzzer blares)
- And guess what?
- [Host] Misery.
- Who was I gonna go with?
- James Caan.
- Trust your gut!
- Shoot!
- I always do.
(host laughing)
- Let's do the next one.
- (laughing) Okay.
(woman screaming)
- Oh please.
(hand slapping)
Give me a fucking break.
(others laughing)
Are you kidding me?
(bell dings)
Really?
- Nailed that one.
- Is that Jamie?
- Yes.
(contestants laughing)
- Three for three. Nice, Kyle.
- And I have to do just one more.
(recording of man screaming)
- [Jamie Lee Curtis] Middle.
- I recognize that.
- Bruce Campbell.
- I agree.
- Middle.
- I wanna just give a shout
to "Troll 2", because I
love the goblins in that.
- Okay, fine! Go "Troll 2!"
- All right, "Trolls 2!"
- They're not even trolls
(buzzer sounds)
- Who was it?
- Middle. I should-
(bell dings)
- Oh my God.
- Take me to Vegas!
- This is unbelievable.
- Thank you guys so much.
- Thanks, Dolores, appreciate it.
That was very cool.
- Thank you so much.
- That was fun.
- Thank you.
- Super fun.
- Very fun.
(woman screams)